we was trying to build on a wire stunt
that I'd I'd come done a million times
beforehand and it was just one of those
things that went wrong unfortunately my
chest folded into my nose my sternum
winded me and my spinal cord separated I
landed on a crash mat and uh was
paralyzed from that moment
[Music]
on um I was born in rord
uh on the East and east side of London I
was small I had lots of energy and my
parents found a way of channeling that
energy for me and my two brothers in a
gymnastics Club so yeah I was 14 years
old and my gymnastics coach was
approached by stunt coordinator Greg pal
Greg was working on the film Lost in
Space in
1997 um five of us gymnast went down and
it was me that was the right height
height and size for the kid and the
right face shape so I spent the summer
of my 14 year 14 years old at shepperton
Studios um jumping around in rubber
space suits flying on spaceships riding
robots and having the summer of my life
whilst also hanging around with some of
the coolest people in the world and that
first time walking on to like a film set
what's it like ah it's amazing it's
that's what made me fall in love with
the machine uh you go through this giant
stage door it's like an air loock into
fantasy world that was like the first
wow moment in my life and what left the
Lasting Impression was being a young man
that everybody treated me like a like a
professional and I was treated like an
adult and outside my Gymnastics Club
that was the first time that had
happened so um yeah I fell in love with
the machine and I knew from that moment
on stuntman was the career choice for me
in the most like simple of terms for
someone that might have no idea what
stuntman does are you able to just kind
of explain what the purpose is in in
film yeah so we get to done the
character um we obviously not playing
the acting role but um we step in for
actors and um for other like background
performance and we risk our lives for
the sake of Storytelling so um the
things that they can't ensure the actor
to do is what we get to do um what
qualities do you think you need to be
successful at that role um you have to
be flexible willing to be challenged you
have to be a to manage your fear uh
handle pressure you have to um also want
to constantly improve on yourself and
contribute into the giant machine that
is the movie making process what was the
first time that you can remember hearing
about Harry Potter I was doing another
day's work with Greg on the film B
dazzled with Elizabeth Hurley now when
we were shooting that day um on location
nice summer time time Greg mentioned
that to keep to take my phone number and
to keep on the phone cuz there's a
chance he might call me in for a
rehearsal on the Harry Potter films so
then I was called in and I got my first
audition on The Potters um we was trying
to work out how we was going to create
quiddit for film um and the suggestion
of throwing a load of kids out of an
airplane with a broomstick between their
legs is kind of uninsurable so what we
did is we drove down the r way with me
tied to a broomstick on the back of a
truck someone had gifted me a cloak from
the costume department and then um yeah
it was that's how we found out that
quiddit was going to be done we finished
the test Chris was whooping and
hollering saying yes we've got it and
then he said to Greg um Greg he was
amazing David thanks very much you were
really in it and then Greg he's our guy
so that's how I got the job that's
amazing yep first quidditch player in
the world you obviously became the stunt
double for Daniel Radcliffe not just
Daniel on the first couple of films I
doubled all of them all of them yeah
first time you see me is I'm actually in
a wig on the floor as the troll smashes
through the bathroom cabinets um that's
me lying down as uh all of the explosion
like the doors explode around us so yeah
I doubled Harry Ron herione Neville
Maloy on uh the first two films did you
have a favorite to be double for
obvously
Harry and your relationship with Danny
Radcliffe is a massive part of your
story how did my boy yeah like he's one
of my best friends he still is to this
day we speak all the time and everyone
got to watch him grow up in front of
camera I'm lucky enough to get to watch
him grow as a man behind and I could not
be proud of an individual his
physicality on the early films was um
something that needed to be worked on
he'll openly admit that we first saw him
swing the bat and the ball up in uh
orwick castle and it's when Greg removed
his cigar out of his mouth and he said
we got some work to do with him so um
Daniel would come into the stunt
Department uh twice a week maybe three
times a week and I'd be his PE
instructor so I'd teach him gymnastics
and then we' do Judo we' do trampolining
jump off a portal cabins and it was an
environment that we could create for him
where he could just be a kid without the
pressures of a giant movie Machine
behind him I mean the insurance company
would have had a heart attack if they'd
have seen what we was getting up to but
also it was a great place for Dan to
develop his physicality and for our
relationship to also develop so when I
see him now and his physicality I can
vicariously live through that brings me
much joy and I always say if he gets the
Wolverine job I'm going for Professor
Xavier um and when you started what was
the age difference you you were slightly
older than I was 17 and Dan was 11 so 17
years old given the freedom of a city
and a pum to spend on alcohol was uh
yeah there was lots of Adventures so I'd
finish work and just go out partying and
in terms of the the stunt team the team
you were working with and the other crew
how did those relationships evolve and I
suppose that team you've got to have the
ultimate trust in each other yeah
absolutely you you have to build up that
trust over you know inside and outside
of work if if you're on fire and you're
waiting for someone to put you out then
you want to know they're going to be
there so yeah it was really important to
to build on those relationships and
whenever you go away and work on a
production uh the stunt Department are
always the most fun Department to hang
around with the cool ones
always in all those films is there a
stunt that you perform that you're
particularly proud of or that is the
most like exciting there's too many
stories to tell you um I enjoyed the one
you know when Harry and Maloy doing the
jeweling sequence uh that stunt there
was pretty cool I was doubling Malo and
I was wrapped around a wire and as the
wires pulled I opened up rotate spin
around and then land split legs right in
front of Alan Rickman I remember one
take just nearly hitting Alan Rickman
and he looks down at me in only Alan
Rickman way you know this the best Snape
delivery ever and picks me up and throw
me back down the table towards Harry
again and uh yeah nearly uh kicking
Rickman and also just interacting with
that man like you he was very very
special individual and when he was in
the Snape costume you knew he was in the
Snape costume so 2009 when you're
filming Deathly Hallows obviously that
was a day that changed your life forever
changed my life forever it was a stunt
that I'd rehearsed many times before and
in stunt action if you're not trying to
develop and build on what is already
been done then you're not really doing
your job properly um we was trying to
build on a wire stunt that had I'd come
done a million times beforehand and it
was just one of those things that went
wrong unfortunately my chest folded into
my nose my sternum winded me and my
spinal cord separated I landed on a
crash mat and was paralyzed from that
moment on my stunt coordinator went and
grabbed my hand and said squeeze my
fingers realized I'd lost finger
function um at the time I had two arms
unfortunately I've had some like
problems with my injury so I've lost one
of them but um I couldn't squeeze Greg's
hand I'd broken enough bones in my
career and as a gymnast to know that
this was a very big injury so yeah it
was that moment on I was a bit like ah
I'm not going to be going back to work
tomorrow even though that was uh the
thing I wanted to do the most I'll
always say breaking my neck made a man
of me I was a 25y old boy all of a
sudden I was faced with a devastating
life-changing injury and it made me grow
and what was the injury that you had
sustained so I had separated my C7
vertebrae so C6 C7 so two parts of my
spinal cord in the um clavical region
this part of my neck um was dislocated
and so as that dislocated it caused
massive amount of bruising in my spinal
cords which killed the nerve fibers so
um yeah I'm uh here now though I'm alive
and uh yeah it's I live to tell the tale
and in life you're either a victim or a
Survivor I am a survivor the support and
the reaction from the cast and crew and
your loved ones in those months how how
was that hard of course it was really
really hard um but I learned very
quickly that the hardest part of it is
seeing my pain in my loved one's eyes so
being strong for myself and for them
helped me get through it and everyone
get through it with me I mean talk about
accountability one of my best friends
Tom who's with me today he's one of my
PAs and been working with me for 14
years I've been in his arms as much as
his own son he's picked me up carried me
all around the world we've been on
adventures together and he's been there
through the good and the bad times in my
life and uh I couldn't be more blessed
to have someone more committed to me in
my life so that's just one of the men
that I'm fortunate enough to have in my
life
surviving this thing and building up to
me being able to live my life it's not
just my PAs it's not just the stunk
Community it's not just the NHS It's a
combination of my family friends
everyone like you know all those people
like I say it takes a village to survive
a spinal cord injury I'm very blessed to
have a giant village of a lot of people
that love me I think that's Testament to
you
though I don't know you know I can be
cheeky do you think your story has
impacted attitudes and practices within
the film industry big time yeah there
was uh massive changes across giant
Studio pictures uh when regards to the
processes of stunts uh the communication
process the actual technical side um my
best friend Mark uh who went on to
double Harry after my injury uh he's
then gone and forged a career in
developing new techniques safer
techniques him performing stunts like
the one that happened that put me in
this situation so yeah it was an very
unfortunate accident but to know that
it's had a it was uh the spark for
change is a silver line on a very dark
cloud for me where did you end up like
channeling your focus and your passion
um for a while I was trying to rease an
old life you know going to our be
through and having parties and taking
friends away and renting Villas and all
of that lot and then I went traveling
for a bit and I've seen quite a lot of
the world um but now I tend to focus on
like Outreach to people within the
disabled Community uh try and encourage
young people to follow their dreams in
the creative arts and uh yeah just
sharing perspective I think Daniel rff
said the story that mattered the most to
him from the whole Harry Potter making
process is yours why did you decide to
tell it together now Daniel always
wanted to turn the camera onto me and
onto my story and it took some
convincing but I was also very conscious
that Harry Potter means a lot to a lot
of people and uh I never wanted to
tarnish that you know right now there
are children in Conflict zones all
around the world watching Harry Potter
on phones and it's making them feel safe
so to bring a story like breaking my
neck to it was something I never really
wanted to do but now the the audience
have grown they're rediscovering the
films with their own children and I
think it's probably the right time to
just you know shed a light on not just
the stunt department but my story and
all of the other people that contributed
to me being alive to this day what can
Society do to be better to individuals
like yourselves that have disabilities
or okay we have a long way to go there
are many instant I've made to feel like
a second class citizen on my travels all
the way around the world and in this
country I cannot get on the public
transport system from my home address in
Essex and get through London navigate it
on my own in a wheelchair without having
to call assistance without having to
fight against uh the system so it's
about time that we start to see people
past their
physical challenges and their physical
fixtures and actually see that there's a
human being there with all of the rain
of what it is to be a human wants
desires needs happiness sadness all of
it it's not just a life sentence it is a
life guidance what do you think over the
years has been the thing that you're
most proud of
oo tough one I think to hold on to me my
sense of self like it changed my body it
didn't change who I am and uh yeah that
that's something I'm proud of and what
have you learned the most about yourself
um can I swear of course you can I'm a
tough [__] yeah yeah um yeah
despite all the challenges the bumps in
the road I still manag to always wake up
and want to look for the light and
sometimes you have to ride the waves of
life not get swept away and I have very
big waves extreme ups and extreme Downs
I mean right now I'm lad by Studios
looking at you find people um not many
people get that opportunity so um at the
same time a week ago I was stuck in bed
cuz my pain was so bad so I've just
learned to ride those waves what do you
want people to take from hearing your
story um I don't know take from it what
you will what you want take it from
someone that's lost a lot of feeling
anything that makes you feel as a human
being don't run away from it embrace it
and how are you now alive in some
capacity still smiling still got a
thirst for Life still got hopes wants
dreams desires and like wanting to tell
more stories keep working in the
creative industry build businesses help
support other people that are going
through spinal cord injury like just
it's not what you take from the table in
life is what you bring to it I want to
bring a lot to the table so um watch to
this space honestly on behalf of like
everyone that's ever watched Harry
Potter like it's been such a big part of
my life so just thank youz that's cool
there is a lot to be learned from the
perspective that people like me can
bring to your platform so embrace all
aspects of what it is to be human um the
good and the bad in yourselves and in
others so the stun coordinator was going
to fire the airam so it had a a lead
with a button going to him offset when
he does fire the button I'm virtually in
line with the ground so he fires the air
R which fires me straight onto the back
of my neck and literally I'm lying on
the floor and I can't feel my legs